we are in the middle of a pretty intense
heatwave and it does not seem to be
letting up and going on for a while in
fact outside our studio today it was
over 90 degrees it's crazy what do you
think of this heat Andy o ha - jet clear
mr. O'Brien it's hotter than two pigs
fighting over a chili pepper god I'm
sorry I guess it's happening again you
see whenever it gets really hot outside
Andy has a strange allergic reaction
that turns him into an old Southern
gentleman I just hope it doesn't get
worse we can go on with the show
oh it's all
[Applause]
tonight this is chose not to get crazier
than a kangaroo with a pouch full of
crowd at his present this is bad and
he's actually sweating seersucker and
it's for him to suit around his body he
seems to have a kind of a heat rash that
also is in the shape of a large hat I'm
really worried that Andy's becoming more
southern by the second I hope it's over
soon I'm afraid this is bad Andy has now
become a southern revivalists preacher
clearly this is a ball son I got the
antidote for your wicked bite and its
name is Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior
no now ladies and gentlemen do not
encourage him when he's in preacher mode
it's a very dangerous mode you're just
hide shading his sweat glands which is
making his allergic reaction even worse
right now we have to focus on getting
andis heat allergy under control and
just hope this doesn't get any I'm agin
um I think you boys don't want to go to
regions look ill away
are you a Jewish person because it seems
like you're afraid to get your hands on
a little pigskin
and ease now become uh intolerant
college football coach at a Division
three school in Alabama the heat has
really got ahold of him I'm concerned
about Andy I don't think he could get
any more southern this I really don't I
hope you get oh God
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this is bad Andy
this is really bad Andy has turned you
to Kentucky County Clerk Kim Davis
oh yes yes we we know you met the Pope
yeah
and you know I don't like what I see
happening with you and that and they
fella your union is against God any
night you're not getting married there's
no and also you're Andy for God's sake
I'm a lady
we're gonna move this on
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography